[Music]
that is a spacex rocket on the launch
pad ready to take a new crew to the
international space station for
halloween
navy lieutenant commander caleb barron
and three colleagues will be there for
the next six months she has already
spent years on a series of
groundbreaking missions under the sea
mark strassman is at the kennedy space
center this morning mark what an out of
this world assignment
yeah it's uh it it really is a
spectacular and special moment whenever
these uh whenever these boosters go up
jamie good morning to you yeah this uh
this
rocker behind the that you see bright
and early sunday morning 2 21 a.m it's
going to lift off three americans all
nasa astronauts and one german lifting
off from launch pad 39a behind me kayla
baron you mentioned well you're about to
see she's got quite the appetite for
adventure
space feels like a good fit for kayla
barron her career has thrived at the
extremes
now 34 lieutenant commander barron was
among the u.s navy's first women
commissioned as a submarine warfare
officer
her sub the uss maine carries 24.
missile away nuclear ballistic missiles
after living hundreds of feet below the
ocean's surface
she's about to soar roughly 250 miles
above earth
this is the most dangerous thing i've
ever done
for me being on a submarine felt pretty
safe does it feel as though you're going
from living in a metal can underwater to
living in a metal can up in space
exactly i mean to me when i look at the
space station i mean i don't know what
other people think about but i go that's
a submarine in space i think about that
every time i see it it's got a better
view though having windows is a nice
upgrade
barron stepped into her first astronaut
suit as a third grader but she first
seriously considered joining nasa while
serving on that submarine
even now launch weekend actually going
to space seems otherworldly this will
actually be the first rocket launch i've
seen in person and i'll be in the
capitol on the top of it there's this
photo of you you've got your arms
wrapped around
the booster they told us they were going
to take us on a tour and i was like i'm
going to hug it you want to you know
just let the booster know that you're
excited to see her and can't wait to see
her on the launch pad she's a baron but
not the german in this spacex crew
that's astronaut matthias maurer joining
them two more nasa astronauts pilot tom
marshburn the only space veteran aboard
and commander raja shari how do you view
the risk of space flight it's all about
taking
risk and balancing risk versus reward so
to your question i think we've made
vehicles that are safer than anything
we've had in history and that's the the
proof of that is now we're starting to
fly private astronauts during their
six-month stay a japanese billionaire
will arrive on a russian soyuz followed
by axiom one the first all-civilian
foursome to visit the iss we're gonna be
busy up there every single day so having
a four guests show up at your house
where you also work is is a challenge
for sure for us it's really cool to be a
part of that history we're excited to
welcome them into our house
this crew capsule is also going up to
space for the first time although spacex
has used this booster before and one
final fun space fact uh with these four
astronauts the total number of people
who have ever been to space will top 600
for the very first time
jamie
love a fun fact mark thank you